is there um
advice you can give to young folks we
talked we gave a bunch of advice on
middle school
high school mathematics is there more
general advice you would give about
how to succeed in life how to learn for
high school students for college
students
career or life in general so i think the
first one would be
to make sure that you're learning to
invent and to make sure you're not just
learning how to mimic because a lot of
times
you learn how to do x by watching
somebody do x and then repeating x many
times with different inputs
i'm just being very generic in
explaining this but i guess this is just
my own
attitude towards the world i didn't like
ever following anyone's directions
exactly
even if you told me this this is the way
to do your homework is to write in
pencil i would say
but i think ken is nice let's try right
so i've been that kind of a funny person
but i do
encourage that if you can learn how to
invent as your core skill then you can
do a lot but then the second piece that
comes with that is something i learned
from my phd advisor
phd advisor which was well make sure
that what you're
working on is big enough and so in that
sense i
usually advise to people once they have
learned how to invent
ideally don't just try to settle for
something comfortable
try to see if you can aim for something
which is
hard which might involve a campaign
which might be important which might
make a difference
and it's more of i guess
rather than worrying what if you didn't
achieve that
there's also the regret of what if i
didn't try
see that's how i operate i don't operate
based on did i succeed or fail it was
hard anyway
if i did this novid thing and the whole
thing failed would i feel terrible
no it's a very hard problem but would i
have had the regret
of not jumping in yes so it's that
different mentality of don't worry about
the failing part as much of the
make sure you give yourself the shot at
those potentially unbounded
opportunities
you